the my waxey keep it up men feel that  they've done quacks iike peeping see how  there's emotion and there's  intentionality and there's anticipation  but there's no meaning meaning is just  the cherry on the cake becomes very very  late in that process and one of the  strange things about us as a species is  our absence of an emotional vocabulary  you know we we have 10,000 words to  describe the process of binding a book  for crying out loud but when it gets  down to emotion we have you know I love  you I hate you and I'm not sure and and  yet if you pay attention to your mind  the subtlest and most kaleidoscopic  dimension of your being is the shifting  screen of your emotion and yet we can  convey only the tiniest part of that to  each other a place like Esalen is built  on trying to open the valve to emotional  language so that people can say what  they feel most people including myself  I'm sure to have not the clue as to how  you begin to say what you feel